est ce que votre promesse d'amener au
canada 25 mille réfugiés syriens
ici la fin de l'année c'est toujours
possible vous y tenez toujours oui oui
moi ils réservent aux visées de garder
notre promesse d'avoir 25 mille réfugiés
syriens
ici au canada avant le 1er janvier
nous allons agir rapidement pour amener
ces gens au canada nous n'avons pas
d'annoncé 10 ionel aujourd'hui mais nous
aurons des annonces détaillées dans les
jours qui viennent
à la veille du départ du premier
ministre trudeau pour le g20 en turquie
son gouvernement a réitéré qu'il
travaille pour que 25 mille réfugiés
syriens arrivent bel et bien en sol
canadien avant la fin de l'année tasha
michel et daniel qui était à ottawa
bonsoir à vous trois d'abord j'aimerais
qu'on commence par monsieur trudeau losc
a eu une emmanuelle il faisait allusion
à un éditorial dans le new york times
aujourd'hui qui disait que c'était une
antidote au cynisme je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez il ya trois mois quand un
conte un stratège conservateur avait dit
à la veille du premier débat
mais si justin trudeau se présente avec
des pantalons il va avoir dépassé les
attentes
aujourd'hui on compare il obtint le
compare à barack obama et à john kennedy
qu'est ce qui s'y passe est un jeu
parfait les grands pantalons ça à m je
pense que le new yorkais phénomène qu'on
voit qu'on constate que les gens
répondent très bien à l'image que
prétend monsieur trudeau et sa femme et
sa famille dans le monde je pense que
comme canadiens en dépit de sa pensée
politique c'est une chose positive pour
le canada d'être reconnu d'avoir un chef
qui n'est qu'il représente pas le
cynisme qui est optimiste qui est
positif et plusieurs jeunes aussi des
petites poupées en carton ont peuvent et
habillé monsieur trudeau avec des
pantalons non sérieusement c'est allé
aussi loin que ça mais écoute le fait
que le monde en amour avec notre premier
ministre et c'est pas une mauvaise chose
du tout espérons qu'il sera à la hauteur
de ce g20
est une bonne réception je pense qu'il
va savoir annuel moi je vais offrir une
poupée un carton attacha très heureuse
effet il a posé depuis le début tous les
bons gestes il a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait faire il ya pris les décisions
faciles à prendre sauf une sur les eaux
usées de montréal cela passe un peu
moins bien c'est toutes les allures web
on sait ça sauf que il ya beaucoup
tape-à-l'oeil là dedans et sauf que le
premier ministre le turdu n'a pas encore
gouverner alors de comparer à barack
obama attendons voir barack obama à une
présidence en demi teinte de comparer à
john f kennedy
j'attendrai très très très très
longtemps celui met beaucoup de pression
sur les épaules c'est de créer des
attentes énormes
le contexte difficile à le new york
times je sais pas qu'est ce qu'ils ont
mangé
ils ont été très inspirés mais écoutez
si vous regarde ça de l'extérieur oui
tout et brouille canada tout à coup tout
le monde respire tout le monde est
heureux mais attendez un peu ça va un
peu vite je trouve michel est ce que ça
peut tenir sinon ça va tenir beaucoup
plus longtemps à l'extérieur du canada
je pense que qu'à l'intérieur
je trouve que la comparaison avec
monsieur obama est excellente mais obama
dans le monde figurent aux états unis ça
va pas mal moins bien monsieur qu'est
née des bons je pense que paul hutin
n'est pas resté assez longtemps pour que
le phénomène de l'usure se manifeste
pleinement
mais dans quel monsieur trudeau monsieur
obama et coûté qu'un
il a été élu là je me souviens des gens
qui étaient allés travailler comme
bénévole à sa campagne qui était revenue
là complètement gaga en disant écoutez
la politique dans le monde va changer à
partir de maintenant ça sera plus jamais
pareil et on a vu ce qui s'est passé ils
vous savez la police extrait d'un espace
de condensé de la nature humaine dans ce
qu'elle a de plus grand et aussi de ce
qu'elle a de plus petits et un moment
donné en chant monsieur trudeau ou pas
plus que monsieur obama va changer de la
nature humaine est il à la politique va
reprendre ses droits les problèmes vont
s'accumuler et monsieur trudeau va
devoir y faire face comme tout le monde
mais pour le moment je reconnais que
c'est beau le canada et le canada est un
pays coule avant tout le monde tout le
monde ira lui valeur que pour les
souverainistes quand même c'était ça
représentait un défi aussi partie oui
oui parce que monsieur trudeau et
defacto le chef des fédéralistes au
canada mais temps et ils viennent de
prendre
il vient de prendre le virage jeunesse
que le parti québécois a manqué je pense
l'occasion de faire durant la dernière
course ce qu'ils voulaient qu'ils
étaient des partisans d'alexandre
cloutier pas c'est exactement ça on va
avoir un nouveau chef qui va plaire à la
jeune génération
et finalement ils ont fait un autre
choix mais du côté de monsieur trudeau
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'attrait
pour la jeunesse dans le personnage le
comportement de langage même de monsieur
trudeau daniel c'est vous qui avez fait
la vision alors diversement ce fameux
grand déversement à montréal mais je
vous pose la question alors est-ce que
c'était la bonne décision la part de la
nouvelle ministre de l'environnement de
l'accepter de le permettent je pense que
je pense qu'ils avaient pas beaucoup le
choix moi ce qui m'agace tu m'a agacé un
tout petit peu là dedans c'est que bon à
voir denis coderre avant qu'on a dans sa
décision il était tout heureux ça à
toutes les allures d'une décision qui
s'est prise entre des amis libéraux de
l'hôtel de ville de montréal et les amis
libéraux à ottawa on vous pose des
conditions presque vide on ne se connaît
a dit oui oui ce sont de bonnes
conditions d'accès de tous à salaire
d'une entente qui a permis aux deux
côtés de sauver la face c'est pas une
solution c'est pas une décision qui va
marquer ce premier mandat du
gouvernement trudeau
heureusement elle arrive dès le départ
mais quand vous voyez la réaction au
québec qu'au canada dans le monde
c'est pas vraiment la décision politique
qui sera cite en exemple dans les livres
d'histoire
bon il y avait comme autre retour à la
réalité il ya les réfugiés aussi parce
qu'on n'a toujours pas le plan
détaillant commence en avoir vibré mais
il ya toujours pas le plan détaillé du
gouvernement d'achat pourquoi est-ce que
justin trudeau 1,6 de temps pour tenir
cette promesse même s'il est beaucoup
d'experts disent qu'il faut peut-être
pas aller si vite que ça
je pense que c'est parce que c'est très
symbolique se symbolise non seulement
été le canada humanitaire revenu sur la
planète comme un essai de montrer mais
aussi c'était très important dans
l'élection cette question je pense
surtout que la question des réfugiés de
la question d'identité mais je pensais
c'est un danger potentiel pour monsieur
trudeau et ça me joins pas ce que tu as
dit michel dans l'autre sens que
maintenant ça va être sérieux comment
est-ce qu'on va rentrer ces gens là est
ce que c'est possible ce que c'est
faisable
ça me surprend un peu de sa fermeté là
dessus parce que je pense que le public
leur ai pardonné dans un sens il avait
dit écoute ça va prendre un peu plus
long peut-être six mois utilisent
semaine pour faire ça ne vous
correctement baissier des problèmes de
sécurité ou autre c'est il va avoir des
problèmes avec ça est-ce que c'est pas
risqué pour lui
michel sais je sais que c'est un
symbolique quand même oui c'est
symbolique
les très symbolique comme cache l2 et ça
a été un tournant dans la campagne je
pense la crise des migrants et elle me
suit trudeau en est bien conscient
maintenant moi la question de la
sécurité ça me je pense ça m'énerve pas
beaucoup d'abord les gens ont voté ont
voté contre le discours de peur de
monsieur de monsieur harper et si on
additionne les voix libérales aseel du
npd je pense que les gens n'achetaient
pas en majorité ce discours là lorsque
le danger pas tellement là bon il faut
faire des vérifications mais il ya une
logistique compliquée dans cette
histoire et je pense que il c'est juste
le début il ya des gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils écoutent et on veut on va avoir
plus de réfugiés par la suite il va
falloir en accueillir davantage année
après année alors si le bordel
s'installe dès le départ parce que
logistique il pas au point que les
mesures d'intégration sont pas au point
que les écoles sont pas capables
d'accueillir les enfants etc
mais là ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile par la suite
de vendre la venue d'autres réfugiés qui
vont en avoir besoin tout autant que
ceux qui vont arriver là alors le risque
je pense il est davantage pour la suite
des choses que dans l'immédiat mais
daniel ont parlé des attentes
on a aussi ce trudeau ils arrivent ils
arrivent au g20 bon c'est on le disait
le premier ministre le plus sexy de la
planète
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas entendu le plus
cool avec du tattoo mais là il va se
retrouver devant vladimir poutine devant
un gala merkel est-ce que ça mais pas
beaucoup de pression sur lui ça met
beaucoup de pression
c'est là qu'on va voir si monsieur
trudeau peut jouer dans la cour des
grands s'il est capable de parler d'égal
à égal avec les obama avec les merkel
joue avec les bladimir poutine ou
françois hollande vous savez quand ils
voient ce soir devant devant angela
merkel elle les tatouages monsieur
trudeau ça l'intéresse pas beaucoup qui
soit cool c'est que c est qu il est de
gauche ça la dérange rassure n'en a pas
beaucoup elle veut savoir qu'est ce
qu'il en coûtera 100 ou 120 le canada
quel rôle je veux jouer le canada sur la
planète quelle est la nouvelle
philosophie de politique internationale
du canada donc il n'y a pas besoin de
tout faire la première fois on s'attend
pas à ce que dans ces quatre sommets là
ils soient de pierre trudeau son père ou
doit les mener à une certaine époque
mais on s'attend à ce qu'ils soient
capables de parler d'égal à égal avec
ces gens là qu'il ait des choses à dire
au nom du canada qui sont différentes de
ce que disait stephen harper c'est un
gros défi d'achat est certainement parce
que ils positionnent déjà le canada
comme un exemple sur la question des
réfugiés un exemple dans le monde sur
trudeau l'a dit qu'on demande aux autres
pays de faire plus l'allemagne
évidemment a fait a fait plus que que
tous
mais les autres pays de l'union
européenne en particulier qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire et aussi la question
des énergies fossiles et les subventions
c'est une grande question qui sont venus
non seulement au g20 mais à paris aussi
la conférence sur le climat s'est se
parler les pays
des énergies fossiles et en même temps
on va couper les émissions de carbone
alors il ya un certain poids crise est
là dedans et comment ce monsieur trudeau
va se positionner là dessus
bon j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu du
québec on l'a un peu négligé une petit
bec avec 7,7 élections fédérales
parlant de la caq michel parce que quand
même il ya eu des résultats très
décevants pour françois legault aux
dernières élections partielles
ça veut dire que le virage nationaliste
qu'il voulut donner en tout cas dont il
a beaucoup parlé sa poche joué en sa
faveur
non bien évidemment les khakis vous
iront écouter les détails de notre
projet ont été dévoilés en fin de
semaine dernière à la veille de
l'élection donc ça a pas eu le temps de
paix reconnais mais dans la réalité des
choses ça fait un an à peu près lors que
monsieur le goût de toutes les manières
la annonce un virage plus nationalistes
plus identitaire alors je pense les gens
savent pas mal ou est-ce qu'il veut
aller et il le problème c'est que
et même chez les électeurs cac est on
est très satisfait des gens ne croient
pas à la possibilité d'une entente qui
conférerait plus de pouvoirs au québec
chez les acteurs caquistes un sondage
interne ce parti c'est 76 % 3 sur 4 qui
croit pas que ce soit possible alors
dans la réalité des choses les gens
voient que bon il ya deux de vrais choix
le canada plus ou moins comme il est et
la souveraineté et monsieur legault
entre les deux et comme dans les limbes
c'est comme si dans le fond ils posaient
de la question aux gens est ce que vous
aimeriez que le québec est le climat de
la californie tout le monde serait très
contente
mais tout le monde sait que c'est pas
possible c'est je pense la première
tâche c'est d'essayer de convaincre les
gens que l'ip en train d'inventer des
histoires simplement pour se positionner
pour la prochaine élection est lui qui
pourtant il ya quelques années dit elle
tout ce qui est constitutionnel
personnes entendues
oui puis un peu plus tard un peu plus
tôt avant ça il disait qu'il fallait
absolument faire l'indépendance vedette
à voir monsieur je suis le goût du chant
j'ai dû me daniel le fait que ce la
présidente dents saines présidente de
l'acat qu'est devenue maintenant
dominique anglade est devenue députée
libérale certains disent qu'elle va
bientôt être nommé ministre
est ce que c'est ce qu'on peut se
demander si paul le clou dans le
cercueil d'accord c'est sa victoire
madame anglade et pas spectaculaire et
elle arrive pendant dix ans j'ai gagné
je gagne et ça a été absolument
extraordinaire ça peut donner un peu de
temps a fait des couilles en avant de
l'emmener au cabinet sauf que est ce que
c'est la fin de la caq écouter à prédire
la fin d'un parti politique c'est
toujours très présomptueux je l' ai déjà
fait je me suis trompé royalement je
leur ferai sûrement pas qu'elle soit que
je me pose moi est ce que est ce que
québec solidaire on peut plus d'avenir
que la caq cepex cette voie très social
démocrate très à gauche très bien défini
acquis aux qui a qui pourraient
peut-être s'imposer davantage dans une
prochaine élection
je ne fais que poser la question je le
sais pas mais je regarde aller les
choses et je ferais mieux de partisans
de québec solidaire que de la cacophonie
est ce qu'on peut dire juste un mot en
terminant sur la rémunération
députée vasso reportage salaires qui
travaille fort oui bah écoute oui très
fort sauf que c'est pas un bon moment
comme on dit dans la politique avec les
manifestations qui se font l austérité
qui se pratique toujours en ontario ils
ont vécu la même expérience a fait
depuis presque une dizaine d'années que
ces jolies la rémunération des députés
là il va pas être changées avant 2019
pourquoi parce que justement on peut pas
quand il est difficile tant les
problèmes économiques justifiaient ça
malgré le fait que wim site a connu
l'enfer et consistant à 10 ce samedi
mais je pense que oui je pense que c'est
vrai que c'est un coût nul mais c'est
presque un cliché maintenant dire qu'il
n'y a jamais de bon moment pour ça mais
il y en a des pires cadeaux
imaginez là que le gouvernement la
présente son projet de loi puis dans
deux semaines il présente un projet de
loi spéciale pour imposer un gel de
salaire aux employés de l'état
voilà alors évidemment de taille mais il
est terrible ceci étant dit il ya quand
même moyen de faire une certaine
pédagogie l'on dit steph rayant les
salaires augmentent de 3 31% mais si on
parle du salaire brut sont pas loin du
salaire net
les gens qui reçoivent leur chèque de
paie ils savent qu'un coup déduit
l'impôt les cotisations à sia ça n'en
reste pas beaucoup alors si dans le cas
des députés le montant net est il le
même qu'aujourd'hui bas une femme c'est
pas si compliqué si vous expliquez ça c
est ça prend 10 10 mots pour l'expliquer
c'est trop regarder le regarder le
revenu moyen
merci beaucoup daniel merci tâche à
michel prochain et dimanche à 11 heures
aux coulisses du pouvoir daniel thibault
reçoit la ministre fédéral de
l'environnement catherine mckenna